pour lui l'homme parfait valérie benaïm
le mien non sa lutte africaine à
l'action du
toit ses bananes
raison 33 c'est l'amour fou
castany vous plaît vous êtes très bon
mais j'aimerais bien voir les deux
jeunes
retraités votre poitrine gâche tout
delphine c'est quoi l'homme parfait pour
moi c'est l'homme qui a de l'humour
l'homme qui a du charisme l'homme qui
est sûr de lui ce très important
il est l'homme à qui on peut faire
confiance et ranger tout ça
je me reconnais plus
on veut faire confiance avec l'homme à
qui on peut communiquer et l'homme fidh
elle aussi ça
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
altin sécu toutes ses qualités
elle souligne le dernier
alors oui le dernier point est très
simple voilà la créatrice tout ce
qu'elle a dit mais en vrai on veut pas
un homme parfait parce que nous on est
imparfaite tout si on était avec
quelqu'un de parfait ça nous ferait
complexé on ne voudrait pas sûrs de nous
et donc c'est bien quand même parfois
que les hommes et des petites failles
qu'on puisse plus les emmerder un petit
peu
plus de failles pour vos autour de la
table où la bombe ces compétitions
faudrait demander au monsieur de rendre
les lunettes de ma fille
alors maintenant de faire des vagues
[Applaudissements]
si les
gens vont compter dans ses critères ah
oui la confiance a fait des dt l'humour
mais c'est vrai que toi tu est apte ou
non à part la beauté mal aussi si je
comprends ce avec l'humour avec le
caractère le charisme on essaie on
essaye et la modestie visiblement
[Applaudissements]
mais les mecs qui ont confiance en deux
bateaux à quai les filles ne veulent pas
la beauté mais sans qu avec des beaux
gosses
c'est vrai que ça c'est insupportable
la marelle te dis jamais jamais de me
dire non mais le fille que ça compte et
et tu les vois jamais tu vas toujours
sortis avec des bots basque au tarif
classique autant en vacances tu vois
rarement le lush mots de du club à
partir avec la police a arrêté
des hommes
tu te fais chier les femmes sublimes
mais tu te fais chier en boîte à parler
avec la mort pendant deux heures et tu
la voir partir avec le mec mystérieux
qui est en train de boire
[Rires]
oui
bah castaldi voilà regarde aussi la
trêve au diabète non mais tu étais le
mystérieux toi ah ouais mais c'est toi
qui voyait pas et qui avait porté
sa arrivée à la maison qui vous
voyez pas essayer la maison italienne
coût qui n'est pas content
vous pour que vous leur part fait
l'homme qui vaut bien
il a même dit oui j'ai pas les moyens
d'être très bas ces barrettes de birsa
thomann
pour lever tout malentendu en fait il
dans le film il ya une vous faites tout
la cuisine le ménage et il ya une
application love love ouais ouais
évidemment tu bien intéressé et j'ai
piqué la télécommande en fait pour
l'habitation le flop est donc la
dynamique à mathieu lagarde
alors donnez moi un proctologue
tenir c'était cesser notre
avant-première tu te vois pas qu'il ya
des femmes qui viennent me voir et qui
me disent
c'est normal à date on doit retenir ça
s'appelle toi tu vas voir que ça un
petit club la barre gamins et bout alors
elle elle fait du monde vous êtes des
happenings
j'ai apprécié tout ça l'année prochaine
si nous aurait géré par béatrice et des
happenings par gagner dans cette
émission je vous redis
enfin fermer boutique bord de moi
s'il vous plaît je vais demander à tous
les gens ici de faire un petit peu moins
de bruit car aujourd'hui raymond fit
termine sa sieste
voilà donc raymond merci d'être là en
tout cas ça n'aille pas trop forte
époque la
thématique et la lumière
les trois abattoirs sèche éclater les
trois spots la centrale c'est quoi pour
toi l'homme pas la femme parfaite moi
c'est qui celle qui supportent celles
qui supportent quand je suis malade et
quand je suis heureux que j'ai envie
d'aller avec elle quand je conduis maric
des choses heureuses et en français
sinon
bah quand
tu sais que tu n'as pas ta g des choses
bien quitte à les allées à la personne
partage est à leur honneur j'avais chez
vous jeter des mots
[Rires]
c'est quoi c'est quoi la femme parfaite
pour toi ah ah bah moi je n'en veux pas
de voler ta réplique mais c'est haram
sont à la maison arts et scènes c'est
mes filles son épouse alors lui c'est
beau mois ses
pouvoirs et qu'il a pas osé c'est un
artiste à l'artiste a laissé le toit de
ma gueule vas-y non mais c'est pas
pareil a dit non c'est vrai pas réponse
à la lettre on siffle il a dit c'est
fini un peu pareil elle n'est pas mariée
avec lui toi tu seras mariac pas toi je
le respecterai pour l'instant si
personne n'est pas dans la famille c'est
tout voilà
didier ma femme parce que l énoncé
[Applaudissements]
à ce qu'elle n'a pas fait de chirurgie
et n'est parfaite la femme parfaite
toi tu es célibataire non non pas du
tout alors quand il ya un temps
y'a toujours car c'est avec ta mère tu
vas tu es quand tu poses la question tu
avec quelqu'un il ya toujours qu'avec
quelqu'un
c'est comme quand tu dépasses un certain
âge jeter dans la piscine avec des meufs
au club med et qu'elle te demande tu as
quel âge tu fais toujours pas qu'elle a
jugé qu'à l'achat
à léon tantôt à temps plein au mécénat
et là il ya toujours un taux en fait
trop bas donc toi t'es pas clair non oui
bien sûr pas faire en couches en coton
s'est raccrochée riposte du screamo oui
bah oui j'affiche pas ben oui jacques
juge pas mais bb je monte pas
l'accouchement de ma famille c'est sûr
que ça dit victime je sais rien que ça
ça reste dense à rester tranquilles dans
le privé bien sûr mélange pas tout
c'était comme un geste pas très plus
tard sur les réseaux que 19 mois la 19'
difficile beaucoup en plus j'ai pas eu
de chance j'ai fait l'amour une fois
j'ai même bébé
xavi pas ça me fait plaisir c'est
incroyable merci beaucoup c'est vrai je
les embrasse un peu je crois qu'il me
regarde maintenant la télé les cas c'est
à la maison
je te voyais que je te voyais tout fou
comme la preuve tu me suis pas tu fais
semblant de 6 à 10 je me suis pas mal
d'entre elles aussi nommé challes rigole
non non il est il est comme ça
franchement il est comme ça il est merci
c'est gentil avec le plaisir n'a pas
failli et sequalum bifurquer moi tout de
suite sur france 3 alors évidemment
compagnon mais au-delà de ça moi c'est
quelqu'un qui me donne des ailes
dans des zones où elle est à toi
quelqu'un d'honnête quelqu'un d'intègre
quelqu'un qui est drôle quelqu'un que
j'admire qui est intelligent qui est
brillant voilà mais c'est quelqu'un
surtout qu'ils me donnent confiance en
moi
et moi ça fait beau ça et comme béatrice
je pense que c'est insupportable de
vivre avec quelqu'un de parfait c'est le
début du malheur c'est le début des
emmerdes ça va être tellement chiant
comme la pluie ça va être l'enfer et
vous c'est quoi votre définition de la
femme parfaite la femme parfaite
j'ai mis il ya un animateur ouais on ne
pose pas qui on lui pose pas de
questions me viennent d'être signés
juste part d'un sarthois très bien sans
déconner toit en direct et au bar
sur deux connaît vraiment
je ne sais pas ce qui te
comprends rien à part qu'une faute
d'acquéreur l'apéro la
gg des pestos du sol rocher la non mais
c'est vrai la maison mais c'est
incroyable parce qu'il va qu'est ce qui
va qu'est ce qu'il va penser alors je
disais quelque chose c'est ce que tu
sers à rien alors beaucoup
dix meilleurs ça recommence mais je te
jure que ça va commencer par quel de bon
qu'elle compte parce qu'on parlait dès
l'année prochaine et des chroniqueurs
qui allait revenir on pas à vous le
saurez oui c'est quoi ça il revient
parce qu'il sert à rien et bunge à la
grèce qui est ressorti de la réunion
c'est ça ta force
il change rien du coup média ne change
rien ne soit pas bon l'année prochaine
on t'aurait pas ça le problème je te le
dis vraiment est très bien comme ça mais
dans ces cas là alors on le paye rien ou
le pays boos
ses problèmes et on coûte cher il a
énormément de fait c'est quand on aura
quatre pension alimentaire tu verras ce
que
davis a commenté des listes udc samantha
davies et bien sûr si tu es bien sûr
gilles la femme parfaite c'est la mienne
[Applaudissements]
et c'est moi qui ne suis pas toujours à
son niveau j'ai rien à progresser c'est
leur un cui vous imaginez que je dise
c'est pas fatou la femme parfaite je
vais pas rentrer ce soir
ah non raison des cris des cris à
portrait robot come away with la femme
parfaite oui elle est comment tous ces
rires évanescente lumineuse de même
facture débats parfois
non mais moi j'aime bien les femmes
capricieuse alors en fait avec après ce
même les femmes sion pas non sinon je
m'ennuie tout de suite voilà ouais ouais
il a besoin d'être maltraités non mais
d'avoir la pression et vous tombez nez
devant améliorer ça il va taper tout
n'est pas bon non mais si vous avez
quelqu'un on va là quelqu'un même une
fille qui tient d'une fiction quelqu'un
voilà moi je rentrais de ces cliniques
et les
elle n'est pas là
[Rires]
c'est la clé des lacs et des commandes
sur wii chez mes patients
c'est thierry gaubert ces deux banques
c'est de bonne guerre
devenir parent dont on peut dire devenir
lé haut mettant couple un nom mais je
rigole
[Rires]